he may not be the president yet but
joe biden wants america to hear his
warnings about the pandemic
creating a task force to tackle it
we're still facing a very dark winter
there are now nearly
10 million covert cases in the united
states
last week we topped 120 000 new cases
on multiple successive days infection
rates are going up
hospitalizations are going up deaths are
going up
wear a mask do it for yourself
do it for your neighbor a mask is not a
political statement
but it is a good way to start pulling
the country together coronavirus cases
in the u.s have now surpassed
10 million as daily infections have
surged more than
60 percent over two weeks
mr biden has vowed to bring in a
national mask mandate
to double the number of drive-through
testing sites and improve
contact tracing detail rather than
defiance
something donald trump has often
displayed
his white house is engulfed in a second
wave of infections
his chief of staff mark meadows a
cabinet secretary and the man leading
his legal fight
have covered 90 all attended this
election night party
it is another indication of clear water
between
two candidates i wear masks when needed
when needed i wear a mask okay let me
ask i don't have i don't wear mess like
him
every time you see him he's got a mask
he could be speaking 200 feet away from
it he shows up with the biggest mask
i've ever seen
the country does now have a vaccine on
the horizon
something he longed for but it will
likely long outlive his tenure
cordelia lynch sky news washington